En se disant prête à conduire 1
liste d'union de la gauche aux élections européennes,
Ségolène Royal a réalisé 1 véritable coup politique.
Je vous explique tout,
Ségolène Royal a toujours été connu pour son culot.
Et hier, à l'université d'été de la France insoumise,
elle a encore fait preuve d'audace
puisque personne ne s'attendait à 1 telle annonce.
Elle affirme que la France insoumise
soutient son initiative de
liste unique conduite par elle-même.
Sauf que les insoumis n'étaient pas au courant
de l'annonce qu'elle s'apprêtait à faire,
au point que certains d'entre eux sont tombés des nus
ou ont cru à 1 poisson d'avril.
N'empêche, les insoumis ont
accueilli
cette initiative avec beaucoup d'enthousiasme,
eux qui depuis plusieurs mois
poussent en faveur d'une liste unique de la nuppace
aux élections européennes.
Dans les autres parties de gauche,
cette annonce a été assez mal vécue.
En effet, les socialistes et les écologistes
ont eu l'impression que Jean-Luc Mélenchon et Ségolène
se sont coordonnés pour accentuer la pression unitaire
sur eux et les mettre au pied du mur.
Mais est-ce que ces colonnes royales
seraient en mesure de
rassembler toute la couche derrière elle ?
Alors c'est vrai qu'elle se situe avec oui
distance des insoumis
pour son soutien à Mélenchon en deux-mille-vingt-deux,
des écologistes pour son
engagement en faveur de l'environnement,
et des socialistes de son ancienne famille politique.
Mais c'est goleine,
royale
reste 1 personnalité politique très controversée,
notamment pour ses propos sur la guerre en
Ukraine et à La rentrée,
elle rejoint l'émission TPMP
dans laquelle elle interviendra chaque semaine.
Politique de Ségolène royal
montre en tout cas
qu'elle veut revenir sur le devant de la scène
et qu'elle n'a rien perdu de son sens politique
qui lui a permis d'accéder
au second tour de la présidentielle
en deux-mille-sept.